gracias por continuar en la batalla de
france 24 estamos de regreso para
actualizar las principales noticias en
materia económica junto a jorge hurtado
jorge bueno comenzamos con una de las
noticias del día continúan las protestas
en un importante paso fronterizo no
entre canadá y eeuu contanos qué tipo de
repercusiones puede tener esto bueno
santiago la casa blanca dijo hoy que el
bloqueo a este puente podría perjudicar
la industria automovilística desde hace
13 días los manifestantes exigen
eliminar la obligatoriedad de la
vacunación para los transportistas los
manifestantes mantienen bloqueado el
puente en base de principal ruta de
suministro para la industria
automovilística estadounidense dent y
troy cada día unos 8.000 camiones
atraviesan el paso fronterizo así como
mercancías por valor de 323 millones de
dólares transitan por allí diariamente y
aunque hay una reapertura parcial del
lado canadiense el paso está bloqueado
por la frontera estadounidense el 75% de
las exportaciones canadienses tienen
como destino eeuu el cierre del puente
ya provoca una escasez de piezas en la
planta de montaje del fabricante los
este el antes en windsor ontario que
tuvo que reducir ayer sus horarios el
ministro de preparación para emergencias
de canadá bilbray aseguró que las
protestas deben terminar antes de que
causen un mayor daño a la economía y
siguiendo de cerca a todo lo que es la
crisis en turquía jorge hubo
manifestaciones por los precios de la
electricidad así que bueno los altos
precios continúan en el debate público
de turquía mientras datos oficiales
indican que la inflación interanual de
enero alcanzó casi el 50 por ciento la
mayor en dos décadas economistas
independientes afirmaron que los precios
al consumidor superaría en el 110 por
ciento en enero hoy un grupo de personas
se manifestó por el alto costo de la
factura energética que aumentó entre el
52 por ciento del 127% en enero
dependiendo del consumo si se toma en
cuenta el precio del gas muchas familias
de turquía vieron como su factura se ha
duplicado y hasta triplicado
incluso algunos bares cobran un recargo
adicional de 4 libras a los clientes que
se sienten en las terrazas que tengan
calefacción la ong red de pobreza
con la subida de los precios de los
alimentos la leche y algunas fórmulas
para recién nacidos aumentaron de precio
hasta el 50 por ciento lo que supone un
riesgo de desnutrición para cientos de
niños escuchemos qué decían los
manifestantes hoy
esto es todo lo que podemos pensar ahora
vamos a casa nos metemos bajo las
sábanas no encendemos las luces no
usamos el horno qué clase de vida es
esta
mis facturas de electricidad han
aumentado tres o cuatro veces está
teniendo un gran impacto en mí estoy
jubilado y con mi pensión no puedo pagar
esto lo único que queremos es vivir con
dignidad
jorge los precios de la energía van al
alza en toda europa no y en este
contexto italia está preparando un plan
en contra de los altos costos de qué se
trata bueno es lo que ha dicho hasta
ahora mario draghi quien es el primer
ministro italiano el anuncio se da luego
de que el gobierno se haya desembolsado
unos diez mil millones de euros para ese
fin en los últimos santiago según datos
del instituto nacional de estadísticas
los precios de los bienes energéticos
aumentaron en italia este enero en un 38
6% en términos interanuales el ministro
dijo que su gobierno prepara un paquete
de medidas de amplia envergadura para
paliar esta crisis energética
recientemente la patronal confindustria
alertó de que las medidas
gubernamentales no son suficientes y que
necesitan planes a mediano y largo plazo
bueno qué dicen los indicadores de la
jornada bueno empezamos con wall street'
el segundo día de ganancias para wall
street pero hay muchas expectativas por
el dato de inflación que se dará a
conocer el día de mañana la bolsa de
parís siguió con su racha alcista
apoyada sobre todo por el sector
tecnológico y el automovilístico y en
américa latina' la bolsa peruana tuvo un
buen desempeño tras el anuncio del nuevo
gabinete de gobierno de pedro castillo y
para finalizar como siempre la cifra del
día cuál será esta oportunidad la cifra
es siete mil
542 dólares ese es el precio promedio de
entradas al superbowl 2020 y eso que
hubo una rebaja en este precio promedio
hace un mes estaban a 8500 dólares
hicieron promociones entonces porque
muchísimas gracias por este completísimo
repaso a nuestra audiencia y le
invitamos a seguir informándose en
france24 y también en transmitir
cuatro.com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
i